okay the
saints are known for some dramatic
playoff failures in recent years one
came to cap the 2017 season when stefan
diggs caught the minneapolis miracle and
ran it into the end zone he's now
running out of the building and all the
way to buffalo we saw this coming
yesterday when he took the social media
to make it clear that something's going
to happen something happened uh
something did indeed happen last night
chris
stefan diggs traded the bills and look i
i initially was like oh man that stinks
i'd like to see stefan dig stay with the
bills or with the vikings rather and
tell us what the vikings are getting
first round pick fifth round pick sixth
round pick and a fourth round pick next
year that's a pretty impressive haul for
a guy that the vikings clearly were
moving on from because he didn't want to
be there
yeah well yes it is i'm sure there was a
market for stefan diggs though you know
stefan diggs as we talked about
yesterday in some of our videos and
stuff you know he's one of those guys at
the receiver position
that has a very
uh
very big skill set as far as the things
he can do he can really be a legit slot
receiver he can really be a legit
outside i'll beat whoever's playing me
man-to-man type receiver and the bills
hey blood's in the water right now as we
know i mean the pats are there's no tom
brady it's your time buffalo you got all
this money you got josh allen on a
rookie quarterback you know contract you
got a big time defense and you needed to
get that established weapon on that
offense to help out josh allen and help
out the offense in general now they got
a go-to guy not shocked to see this
marriage i know the new england patriots
love stefan diggs when he was coming out
brian dayball the buffalo bills
offensive coordinator was in new england
during that time and i'm so i'm sure you
know that love affair has continued and
he recognizes what stefan diggs will do
for his offense so great great i think a
great trade for the buffalo bills
because much needed and the time is now
and it's great for the minnesota vikings
that they got i don't think i look at
this deal and go oh one side got ripped
off or one side totally got shelled here
you know if you really like the guy and
the player and you think he could take
you to that next step
i think that was an okay price for the
bills to pay and give to the minnesota
vikings see i disagree with you now look
i you feel more strongly about diggs
than i do because i think you have to
take the total package with diggs he's
never had more than 1100 receiving yards
in any one season he's only had two 1
000 yard uh receiving seasons in his
career he was getting paid very good
money he's probably going to want more
money now that we're seeing the market
uh dramatically in increase with the
likes of amari cooper at 20 million a
year and julio jones at 22 million a
year
but i look at what deandre hopkins
generated for the texans a running back
the cardinals couldn't wait to get rid
of in a second round pick i look at
antonio brown last year a third round
pick and a fifth round pick now the
difference is we knew all about antonio
brown's warts and see this is a credit
to the vikings chris for keeping it all
under wraps when diggs went awol after
week four nobody knew what was going on
behind the scenes and the vikings chose
not to go to the media and make diggs
look bad because they wanted to win the
short-term pr battle they kept their
cards close to the vest they never felt
compelled to crap on digs so it never
took on a life of its own and they
didn't jab at him and cause him to go
full bore on social media like brown did
to the point where you can't get
anything for the guy and when you
consider a third and a fifth for brown
last year after everything that went
wrong between him and the steelers and
the quality of the player brown is
that for the vikings to get what they
got for diggs really is a steal so you
know you could say hey arm's length it's
a win-win but when you look at some of
these other deals that have been done
it's like holy crap spelman should have
been wearing a ski mask well but antonio
brown was going to ruin the steelers i
mean he was dragging their quarterback
through the mud every day he had no
contract so that takes away his value of
his trade let alone he is a like the
biggest problem child we've seen in the
nfl the last five years so that's why
that happened you know again when am i
sitting here going do i think stefan
diggs is you know worth that you know
it's debatable for me i'm not saying i
would i'm just saying that the bills i
think think he is that guy and if you do
think he's that guy then you go for it
from that standpoint the other thing too
mike you talk about dick's production
come on mike i mean the minnesota
vikings offense has stumped for like for
the last four years it stinks so
nobody's gonna put up big stats with
that the receivers run three routes they
have three running plays and they run a
lot of blue legs you know so that's not
going to help a guy out in that type of
system either to put up numbers where we
go oh you know that justifies that trade
or anyways the bills seem to like it i'm
with you i don't know if i feel that
strongly about stefan diggs i agree with
you on that standpoint but i think they
see a really great player and a system
fit which probably made them feel
comfortable to give up those type of
assets
he's only 26 as a rookie he had 720
receiving yards with teddy bridgewater
as the quarterback 2016 when it was sam
bradford 903 2017 with case keenum it
was 8 49 2018 with kirk cousins 1021 his
first thousand yard season and then last
year 1103
receiving yards he's had his best two
seasons of his career with kirk cousins
but there's something there with him and
cousins and paul allen was on pft live
earlier today he's the voice of the
vikings and he actually thinks that
diggs going awol after that week 4 loss
at chicago
got kirk cousins to think that there was
something about him that diggs didn't
like and it caused cousins you know to
the extent that we talk about the
external criticism of cousins waking him
up it may have been diggs that woke up
cousins last year and you know it all
has worked out for cousins to get to a
level where the vikings are very pleased
with what he's capable of doing three
years 96 million dollars his new
contract but that moment and the
aftermath of that bears game that may
have gone a long way toward cousins
getting to the level that we now see him
at chris
yeah man maybe it could be i mean of
course that's the same game that adam
thiel will call them out publicly after
the game so
you know that seemed to be a a
definitely huge defining moment you know
for uh the minnesota vikings kirk
cousins to where they turn things around
and you know honestly you know and i
don't know this but
you know i i think diggs frustrations
just from my standpoint on the outside
looking in has more to do with the
vikings offense than it does with kirk
cousins i have no knowledge of that i
can be totally wrong uh but if i was a
receiver and i played that offense the
last two years i don't know if i you
know and i look at the other great
receivers in football i'd go man they're
not doing any of this stuff that they're
doing with these other guys with me
and i'm sure that bothered stefan diggs
to a degree as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports